According to US authorities, the hackers targeted
some of the world's leading corporations.
They breached the networks of technology companies
which remotely manage servers, storage and
other computing tasks and then stole secrets
from their clients.
This case is significant because the defendants
are accused of targeting and compromising
managed service providers or MSPs.
MSPs are firms that are trusted to store,
process and protect commercial data, including
intellectual property and other confidential
business information.
When hackers gain access to MSPs they can
steal sensitive business information that
gives competitors an unfair advantage.
The attacks were allegedly part of a Chinese
campaign known as cloudhopper, with the defendants
working on behalf of China's intelligence
service.
The managed service providers' networks were
infiltrated multiple times in breaches that
lasted for weeks and months.
The deputy attorney general described it as
part of a trend of state-sponsored hackers
breaking into US networks.
More than 90 percent of the department's cases
alleging economic espionage over the past
seven years involve China.
More than two thirds of the department's cases
involving thefts of trade secrets are connected
to China.
China has rejected the USA's allegations of
industrial espionage . the Foreign Ministry
in Beijing is calling the accusations slanderous.
They also state that the US would also have
to withdraw its charges against two alleged
hackers from China.
This dispute is likely to further burden the
already strained relations between the US
and China due to the trade conflict.